enfant on disait de moi que j'étais
bavarde partout à l'école à la maison
chez les copains chez les copines
j'étais bavarde une sorte de constat
partagé par tous mais qu'est ce qu'elle
parle comme cela a commencé à l'école
primaire j'ai très vite compris le
message
elle ne pas se taire un peu alors je ne
sais pas pour les autres mais pour moi
cette injonction social a eu l'effet
complètement inverse
je n'ai jamais eu envie de me taire au
contraire j'ai toujours eu envie de
donner mon avis sur tout quand béatrice
m'a appelé pour me parler de cet
événement quelque chose en moi s'est
allumé c'est comme si j'avais eu tout de
suite envie d'être là devant vous ce
soir
alors bien sûr ce soir je suis là pour
vous dire à quel point il est important
que les femmes parlent pour que d'autres
femmes qui les écoutent puisse parler à
leur tour et que cela constitue une
chaîne qui ne ce qui ne s'arrête jamais
mais ce soir je suis aussi là pour vous
dire à quel point cela fait du bien
parler en public et encore davantage
dans l'espace public c'est se sentir
vivant c'est gagner à chaque fois en
confiance c'est grandir à l'intérieur ce
soir je suis un maillon de cette chaîne
et j'ai envie de vous dire à vous
mesdames qui n'osaient pas essayer
prenez la parole une fois et vous verrez
à quel point cela va vous faire du bien
parce que vous en entendez beaucoup vous
des femmes dans l'espace public
savez vous que l'inégalité d'expression
des femmes remontent aux écrits antique
ou au maire dans l'iliade et l'odyssée
affirme que la parole est une histoire
d'hommes et met alors en scène des
hommes coupant la parole à des femmes
obéissantes où timothée dans le nouveau
testament qui écrit que les femmes
doivent écouter l'instruction en silence
dans une entière soumission
cela ne vous fait pas penser à à l'image
des femmes à l'oeuvre dans nos sociétés
où le fils sont considérées comme du
bonne fille si elle demeure discrète et
silencieuse
j'ai fait une petite expérience aussi
j'ai tapé sur google ou par le les
femmes
et alors j'ai obtenu quatre pages de
recherche ou google ne me renseigner pas
du tout sur les lieux d'expression des
femmes mais où on m'explique que les
femmes parlent plus que les hommes
autrement dit qu'elle parle trop et
google s'interroge avec suspense
de quoi les femmes peuvent-elles bien
parler entre elles parce que c'est de
cela qu'il s'agit
on s'intéresse à au fait que les femmes
parlent trop au restaurant entre copines
les unes chez les autres mais n'est
jamais question de la véritable
expression des femmes pour défendre une
cause ou une idée et c'est encore moins
vrai dans l'espace public
et c'est pour ça que j'avais envie
d'être là devant vous ce soir pour vous
dire comment cela a été possible pour
moi de prendre cette place et d'investir
ces lieux en tant que femme un jour
alors que ma petite fille venait d'avoir
deux ans et que j'avais sérieusement
besoin de retrouver en moi la femme
militante je suis allé à une réunion
pour défendre la maternité où j'avais
accouché la maternité des lilas au lieu
des droits des femmes étaient en danger
et cela me paraissait invraisemblable
alors que le personnel de la maternité
nous expliquer la situation
mon bras s'élever tout seul pour prendre
la parole c'est comme si je me voyais
faire sans pouvoir vraiment réagir la
situation ne me touchez parce qu'elle
parlait de moi de nous les femmes et de
l'importance de ces lieux pour que nous
ayons le droit de choisir
alors mon bras s'élever tout seul pour
dire quelque chose mais joue ce sont
mises à rougir mon ventre s'est nouée et
c'est incroyable parce qu'en même temps
j'ai senti une dynamique m'envahir j'ai
tout de suite compris à ce moment là
qu'il se passait quelque chose de
différent
c'est comme si mon corps savait avant
moi qu'il était important que je parle à
ce moment là et que cela ne s'arrêterait
jamais alors j'ai proposé quelque chose
j'ai dit que je pouvais être là que
j'allais essayer j'ai proposé des
actions et c'est comme si quelqu'un me
pousser dans le dos et qu'il me donnait
une énergie gigantesque et que d'autres
ressentent et cette énergie et qu'ils
avaient envie de me suivre en une prise
de parole ou presque
je suis devenue coordinatrice d'un
collectif citoyen si j'ai pu et su
continuer c'est grâce à une rencontre
ma rencontre
avec maya surduts de maya a été ce que
j'appelle un modèle inspirant maya était
une féministe de 80 ans une vraie
féministe de l'espace public de toutes
les manifestations est de tous les
combats pour les droits des femmes
nous n'étions jamais d'accord ou plutôt
mayenne était absolument jamais d'accord
avec moi maya prenez la parole tout le
temps elle n'avait que faire d'eux qui
vous étiez de ce que vous avez à dire de
vos responsabilités si elle n'était pas
d'accord avec vous elle vous le disais
et cela marchait plus je regardais
j'écoutais maya plus je me disais que si
nous voulions la parole il y avait qu à
la prendre
maya a été l'un de mes modèles
inspirants malgré nos différences de
générations avec mon enfant au sein et
mon congé parental je n'étais pas
l'archétype de la féministe selon maya
mais ça n'est pas grave parce que quand
vous avez un modèle qui vous inspire
vous regarder uniquement ce qui vous
inspire
et vous dépassez le reste la puissance
de l'inspiration suffit cette lutte pour
la maternité aura duré cinq ans ce bras
qui s'est levé mon a fait faire des
choses invraisemblables
il m'aura fait chanter dans les manifs
fait faire des discours sous la pluie il
m'aura fait lancé des pétitions ou
organisé de fausses accouchement dans la
rue et là je vous parle d'une parole
dans l'espace public pas uniquement en
réunion entre pairs une parole -
protéger plus exposés parce que parler
dans l'espace public
au début c'est un peu comme si vous
osiez sortir en pyjama la rue appartient
à tout le monde à personne à la fois et
pourtant quand vous décidez d'y parler
vous avez l'impression que vous allez
voler quelque chose à quelqu'un je me
souviens la première fois c'était sur le
parvis de la mairie le maire a parlé
et puis c'était à moi j'ai tout de suite
senti que c'était différent
il ya les gens qui sont là pour
l'événement avec eux c'est un peu plus
facile
la légitimité est posée mais il ya tous
les autres qui se retourne parce que
votre voix porte les gens ont l'habitude
d'entendre parler le maire de leur
commune les présidents d'associations
les syndicalistes
mais une femme pourquoi est-elle la cat
elle a raconté il ya les curieux et ceux
qui rient et vous avec votre voix qui
tremble votre micro et votre syndrome
d'un poster tout ce que j'ai pensé a été
nourrie par ce que j'ai vécu ce jour là
j'ai compris que c'est dans l'espace
public qu'on peut bousculer les
consciences
c'est dans l'espace public qu'on peut
proposer une alternative un
rééquilibrage à l'espace médiatique et
j'ai décidé de jouer avec cela quand un
matin j'ai décidé d'organiser un
happening et d'organiser de faux
accouchement dans la rue on m'a pris
pour une folle et pourtant c'est
l'action qui a le mieux fonctionné
il s'agissait de faire parler de la
maternité du risque de fermeture et donc
du risque pour les femmes de perdre un
lieu comme celui là nous nous
installions la plupart de temps devant
le ministère de la santé et nous étions
très rapidement entouré de crs car il
est assez rare que nous déclarions notre
intention d'accoucher les femmes jouer à
coucher d'autres à les assister et en
regardant ces femmes je voyais à quel
point cela les animer même si elle
trouvait sacrément gonflé de le faire
avec ce type d'action nous nous sommes
réapproprier l'espace public avec notre
féminin comme les hommes savent le faire
avec leur skate park où leur terrain de
foot venir rejouer des moments aussi
intenses aussi intimé aussi féminin que
des accouchements
cela force l'écoutent et cela a été ma
carte pour remettre les droits des
femmes au coeur du débat
j'ai compris à ce moment là aussi que
dès lors qu'on donne l'autorisation aux
femmes et le sens de la démarche
elle fonce pour occuper l'espace public
d'ailleurs une fois que ces femmes ont
eu fait cet accouchement elle non plus
envie de partir
donc elles ont décidé de continuer à
investir l'espace public comme il savait
si bien le faire elles se sont mises à
camper devant le ministère de la santé
cela a fait des heureux autant vous dire
et elles ont continué leurs réactions la
question de l'expression des femmes dans
l'espace public a été au coeur de ma
décision lorsque j'ai accepté de faire
de la politique parce que oui c'est
risqué c'est risqué de faire de la
politique c'est risquer d'abîmer son
image et c'est risqué de se confronter
aux critiques mais ce risque n'est rien
à côté de l'espace d'expression que cela
me donne ce n'est rien à côté de ce
sentiment d'agir pour l'intérêt général
et encore davantage pour ma part pour
l'intérêt des générations futures
j'ai tout de suite compris que c'était
important pour moi d'être à cet endroit
là et de faire les choses de cette
manière
quand j'ai continué et que je me suis
réapproprié 7 pas cette place j'ai
compris que ça n'est pas ça n'allait pas
être toujours facile parce que c est
véritablement important d'aller chercher
cette place et de ne pas se la faire
voler c'est là qu'on en revient à la
question des modèles des modèles
inspirants parce que moi
depuis petit j'entendais des hommes me
dicter la société en fixer des règles
j'entendais les médecins me dire
pourquoi j'étais malade les professeurs
me donner des notes les directeurs me
dire comment travailler mais des femmes
à part ma mère je n'entendais pas alors
au début j'ai beaucoup écouté puis j'ai
pris la parole une fois deux fois puis
j'ai pris la parole alors que mon avis
n'était pas attendue là c'était un petit
peu plus compliqué j'ai appris à me
faire couper la parole j'ai aussi appris
à lire dans le regard de l'autre quand
ce n'est pas votre voix qui était
attendu sur ce sujet et j'ai appris la
confrontation poli ou plutôt
politiquement correct parce qu'il faut
se confronter toujours lorsqu'on essaie
de vous faire taire il ne faut jamais le
passé sous silence
avez vous remarqué que les femmes
utilisent beaucoup plus de précautions
oratoires lorsqu'elles prennent la
parole est ce que je pourrais vous dire
que pourrais-je avoir une minute pour
vous faire passer mon idée qui trahit
évidemment leur manque d'assurance
une étude de la fondation rockefeller
montre que deux tiers des américains
pensent qu'il est particulièrement
or tant pour les femmes en début de
carrière d'avoir des modèles féminins
dans les postes de leadership ce n'est
pas que les femmes seraient moins bien
faire c'est qu'elles ont moins de
modèles et si je vous dis cela c'est que
à certains moments lorsqu'en politique
je me sentais tout petit j'ai cherché ce
qui pourrait m'aider j'ai cherché ce qui
pourrait me procurer une posture plus
forte et alors youtube a été un ami
précieux j'ai écouté parfois pendant des
heures le volume à fond des discours de
femmes qui pouvaient m'inspirer qui
pouvait me nourrir je pense à beaucoup
d'entre eux mais là je pense notamment à
ce discours de simone veil à l'assemblée
parce qu'il avait forcément quelque
chose d'inédit
simone veil devant une assemblée
majoritairement composée d'hommes 98% il
me semble est particulièrement hostile
prend la parole sa voix est posée
elle est forte son regard est déterminé
ces mots sont particulièrement choisi
elle y va et pourtant elle sait ce
qu'elle risque en écoutant ses vidéos
j'ai compris que c'était ça qu'ils
pouvaient me porter j'en ai regardé
d'autres je passais de vidéos en vidéo
j'ai compris que les femmes pouvaient
prendre la parole elle avait moins 2
millions de vues mais elles m'ont aidé
autant j'ai vu que les femmes prenaient
la parole partout dans le monde et je me
suis dit il est là le secret nous devons
tout prendre la parole même une fois
pour dire quelque chose auquel nous
croyons
il y à des réunions les femmes ont des
accords tacites entre elles elles ne
ressortent pas de réunion tant qu'elles
n'ont pas donné toute leur avis sur un
sujet je trouve cela formidable parce
que cela montre que c'est possible que
solidarité et sororité fonctionne comme
le dit si bien l'avocate et militante
américaine des droits de l'enfant
maryann wright edelmann les modèles sont
là pour nous permettre de nous projeter
dans des rôles que nous n'imaginions pas
ou au mieux qui nous faisait rêver du
knb what you can see en d'autres termes
voir des femmes qui nous ressemblent
tant des rôles nous permettent de nous
rappeler que ces rôles existe mais
également qu'ils sont envisageables pour
nous c'est croire en cette idée qui
m'inspire parce que c'est une solution
qui fonctionne si demain nous voulons
entendre dans l'espace public plus de
voix de femmes qui s'élève
nos enfants ont besoin d'entendre plus
pardon autant de voix de femmes que
d'hommes dans les espaces publics
parce que pense qu'elle ne peut venir
que de la la légitimité d'un modèle
auquel on s'identifie et qui inscrit à
l'intérieur de nous que c'est normal et
vous savez ce qui est magique c'est que
nous tous ensemble ici demain on peut
faire en sorte que cela change
on peut devenir le modèle inspirant de
quelqu'un d'autre mesdames trouver la
cause qui vous parle
celle qui vous pousse même modestement à
aller à changer le monde est allé en
parler dans l'espace public
il ya des milliers de manières de faire
messieurs permettait que la parole des
femmes se libère lycée l'heure de la
place faites-le pour elle mais également
pour le message que vous faites passer
pour vos enfants
nos enfants le mérite si nous voulons
que cette égalité existe nous devons
être
cette égalité permettons à nos enfants
de croire que tout est possible parce
que c'est le cas les rêves de nos
enfants ne doivent pas avoir de limites
quant à moi je remercie l'enfant bavarde
qui continue à l'être et je lui donne la
parole le plus souvent possible